good afternoon everyone welcome this to
this meeting of stratford-on-avon uh
District Council cabinet
and as we start cabinet I should say
that since the agenda went out uh
councilor Sarah Wally hoggins has been
replaced by councilor Bill Fleming so
I'd like to formally welcome Bill to the
his first cabinet meeting
thank you
with your forbearance may I make a short
comment
glad to welcome Bill Fleming to the
cabinet the bidford mafia rules again
yes
so
jokingly joking aside welcome bill it
probably gives you a flavor of the
things I have to put up with this chair
so without without further Ado apologies
for absence on
none Leah thank you discloses of
Interest they will have any disclosures
or take that as a no minutes confirm and
sign a minute of the meeting held on the
18th of July is that Mr chairman yeah
sorry counselor Harvey
um
I hesitate to raise this matter but
councilor Kettle made a point asked a
question on the capital budget
monitoring item 176
um and asked a question how could one
number be bigger than another and there
is a form of Words which has been agreed
within the finance function which
addresses the point
um and either Anne or Richard could
could uh Enlighten us with what those
keywords are which I I request be added
to the minutes
so I could just yeah if I was just read
out
the remaining budget total for the
assets reported in the period 1 to 12 20
21 22 Castle budget out and included
what appeared as an overspend for the
next steps accommodation program but
this was financed by additional cattle
receipts from mhclg reflected elsewhere
within the report
the reported total for the slippage
purely related to the planned
maintenance program therefore
thank you Richard is everyone happy with
that Edition
thank you
so are there any more uh questions on
the minutes
in that case can
I signed the Miniatures a true and fair
reflection of the meeting
thank you
so moving on uh item four leveling up
approach and Devolution deal for
Warwickshire
and uh first thing I should say is it's
been drawn to my attention that on
recommendation three uh South Yorkshire
Foundation Hospital trust is an
incorrect designation and we will
replace that with the correct
designation
so
without further Ado then picking up uh
this and
it's very interesting how much has
changed since uh the leveling up
approach came onto the agenda
and
you know just looking at how much the
world has changed in the last three
months it really is quite incredible
uh we've got a cost of living crisis
energy Security's gone up the agenda uh
food security has gone up the agenda
interest rates are going up
and
we have
an interesting position now on the state
to public finances where uh when Boris
Johnson announced his resignation it
looked as though it was 30 billion spare
now uh that was evaporated so just
picking up in one three one where it
says the leveling upper gender is
regardless of the forthcoming change of
prime minister a government priority and
so we'll continue to have its attention
and a source of resource I think given
what's happened it may well be that the
source of research resources much less
uh if one actually goes through this
there is an awful lot of detail in it
they
uh the appendices are well worth looking
at but I do Wonder
just how much has actually changed and
how much of this will actually be
implemented so it's a good document
it's worth looking at councilor junid
yes as as an ex-scientist who used to
deal with enough data an awful lot
um
I do recognize that a data-driven
approach is good but
um
if you uh if two broader definitions are
used for example taking things at a
super output areas of deprivation Etc I
mean for example if you took the UK is
is the what was the fifth now is the
sixth richest country in the world that
means that everybody's Rich no it
doesn't so again if you're if you take
um things at a too broader level
um you you
um do Overlook small hyperlocal areas
Stratford on Avon District Council is
not included as a key place in here to
address problems of need and inequality
and two of the areas within the um the
district
Ulster Town but also Stratford North
fall just outside these definitions and
I'm sure there are other smaller areas
so I'm just wondering given the comments
you made about current costs and
inflation and energy crisis does this
need addressing and is this something
that we ought to feed back to
Warwickshire County Council after seeing
these this response to the cabinet
I think they will be ongoing dialogue
with Warwickshire County Council and
that will be picked up could I just
raise one point about the issues you
raised you said with the sixth richest
economy we may well have the sixth
largest economy but a far better measure
of how affluent we are is the fact that
in terms of GDP per head we rank 28th
and the reality actually is we are
nowhere near as rich as many people
would like to believe and I think we
need to take that thoroughly into
account councilor Barker
um yeah the the definition used for
super output areas is very much
standardized I'd agree with you on that
but it's something that has recognized
Nationwide
um if you look more deeply into the
Swift part of the uh report you will
discover that we've been working
incredibly hard on working out how to do
these things at a much lower level and
that is one of the drivers behind the
entire way we're looking at place so
there is a complete acceptance that
you've got to start somewhere in the
super output areas identify it
um but you may or may not have ever
heard a County council meeting full
council meeting where people start their
speeches with my division has the lowest
whatever and everybody plays a leveling
down with how it skin to their own
division is so I it's not it's not
always helpful but most of them
obviously have ended up being in the
super deprived areas I hear what you're
saying about those two areas of the town
and Stratford North were aware of that
in terms of the bigger the super output
areas but also there are micro things
and we are looking at families
um communities
can I just say I agree with that I'm
just saying cutting the case be made to
Warwickshire County Council that there
is a need to look at particular
circumstances that may fall outside
their areas of measurement
I I think uh councilor Barker made a
very good point that you've actually got
to start somewhere uh councilor Parry
thank you chair
um I just wanted clarification page 14
paragraph 1.7.5 that the three and a
half million over five three years
actually went to WCC not WDC
could we make
matched his corrected yes indeed I will
absolutely make sure that is correct I
can also confirm that work District
canceled about 3.5 million also over
three years but but yes it should be SDC
so fine
councilor Pemberton
chairman um
because of leave commitments
um I I've attended the last two leveling
up meetings uh sitting in for the leader
ably supported by our deputy chief
executive and on both occasions
I made the case that merely looking at
the super output areas is not the only
game in town there is a lot of work
around as councilor Barker and you
yourself cancel the unit uh mention
around families so
um already ahead of you on that one
we've already already made that point
twice and we'll continue to do so and I
know that councilor Barker has that
front and center on her agenda to ensure
that
by the use of the super output area
approach we don't miss not just uh the
very some very very families in very
very difficult circumstances in this
District but also in other parts of the
county rather than where the the current
focus is so you can have that Assurance
that's been raised on more than one
occasion and will be continually on the
radar
thank you councilor Pemberton councilor
kettle
thank you Mr chairman
um one is one point is just a query
in that on page 19 the county uses the
word a hyper local Focus
um
I've no idea what a hyper local focus is
um and perhaps Mr Barrel clearly knows
because he's smiling he's obviously
enthusiastic to tell me but I've no idea
what that is I think there's quite a lot
of terminology in here which is which is
sort of
normal speak which may not necessarily
be interpreted in the way it's intended
um
the other point I was going to make is
two points one is Warwick District
Council has been used as a trial
and as we know from our
very long experience of working world
work with Warwick they have a very
different approach
to the way things are dealt within
Stratford and therefore
whilst I'm absolutely in favor of all
the proposals going forward we need to
make sure that
there is a a benchmark is is not set for
for our Authority which we know uh from
experience has a very very different
approach to us
um the final point and then I will I
think Mr Butler's got to pick up
um is on page 40.
um place
um four of the five districts are listed
that are being none eaten North
workshire rugby and Warwick
which again is um in a way helpful that
we're not listed as those most deprived
areas but as an authority looking after
the residents of Stratford
lovely we have residents in Stratford
who are equally entitled to be leveling
up
and we need to ensure that because of a
slightly stratospheric view of the whole
Warwick uh that we
um are more deprived for instance get
their Fair proportion of support
Mr Brooklyn did I absolutely agree with
you on that point councilor Kettle and I
think that picks up the points that have
been made earlier by councilors marker
and Junior Mr Brooklyn yeah I'm just
going to repeat exactly that that the
reference to hyperlocal areas is to go a
level below the lsoas which have been
discussed in the report already so it's
recognition of exactly the point the
Council of Junior was making at the
beginning you can have pockets of
deprivation within an lsro but because
there's a general affluence within the
area those communities could be
overlooked and that that's the
recognition there for the phrase and I
think it is a made-up phrase about the
hyperlocalist and make sure you are
getting that information at a much lower
level of detail in relation to the pilot
absolutely why I could the other pile up
but I've always already been contacted
by officers at the County Council to
start developing a Stratford a bespoke
Stratford approach to leveling up as
well so we are being engaged with the
County Council on that and it's going to
be the monetary officer at the County
Council Sarah Duxbury that's leading on
that side for Stratford
okay I think that's a very reassured in
Mr Brooklyn because there is no doubt
about it we want something that's highly
appropriate to our own District
councilor Barker
and I think in a positive way the fact
that we've got to have a hyper local
approach in Stratford plays into our
hands because it will be the places that
really which will be much smaller
because we haven't got a single lower
super output area so because we haven't
gone to Lillington East
um we've got to do something different
and that recognition I think is really
really vital
an excellent point councilor Barker I
think that is well worth reflecting on
and bearing in mind as we go through
this process so having had considerable
discussion and debate on this paper the
recommendations on page 11
recommendations one to five subject to
win recommendation three the
southwestern Foundation Hospital trust
is replaced with the correct
nomenclature uh can I have your
agreement to the five recommendations
please members of cabinet
thank you members of cabinets are moving
swiftly on uh item
five
uh
proposed performance
management framework councilor Perry
thank you leader
um this report presents the proposed
council plan actions for the period 1
April 2022 to 30th September 2023 and
the proposed Performance Management
framework 2223 was approved at the
cabinet meeting on 18th July and the
plan would usually include both council
plan actions and key performance
indicators however due to the uncoupling
of the merger the work originally
undertaken needed to be Revisited hence
there's been a delay to approving the
actions that was proposed
um this report therefore allows for a
review of the council plan following the
elections next year in May 2023 as it
makes sense
for the new Administration next year in
May to develop a council plan for the
period first October 2023 to 30th
September
a comprehensive process and thorough
consultation has been undertaken to
develop the council plan actions my
thanks are extended to everyone involved
in the development of this report so the
options available to the cabinet are one
to approve the proposals to to amend the
proposals or three to request further
work it is my recommendation to approve
the proposed council plan
thank you councilor Parry so any
comments from members of cabinet sorry
counselor Harvey
thank you Mr chairman can I refer you to
um
cp2b
on page 106.
yep
all objectives as far as I'm concerned
need to be achievable otherwise they're
Pie in the Sky
I challenge the inclusion in that
objective of the use of the word all
my challenge would be
if you came back in six months time or
12 months time how would you evidence
that every single resident within the
district had had their health and or
well-being improved
an interesting point councilor Harvey
um
I think it may well be something that we
do need to look at because as you say
technically improving the health and
well-being of all residents might
actually be an impossibility
so we probably need to look at that
again you're looking very critical
councilor Barker
our aim is to improve the health and
well-being of all that's what we've set
out to do and that's
it I don't think we can say some of
I don't think we I don't think we can
reduce it down to a particular group I
think I think they all just has to stay
because of what the intention okay
I think that makes an awful lot of sense
it is the intention to improve fine are
you happy with that councilor Harvey
thank you I thought it was implicit
councilor Parry can we amend that too
absolutely I think it we should it it
really needs to infer that it's an um
it's an ambition yeah
councilor kettle
um
on page one sorry I've got a few points
Mr chairman uh cp1b
work ever more closely with worship
County councilor Harvey I'm I'm slightly
in nickel and dying here but I'm
wondering whether the word ever is
really relevant in this case working
more closely with the Warwickshire is
something
sensible but there is a limit when
working with Warwickshire needs to come
to a an appropriate
um stop not so much to stop but there's
only so far we can go so I'm slightly
concerned about what you still had ever
in that one
um over the page
cp2a promote enhance protect the
cultural heritage and natural assets of
the district
um now you will be aware Mr chairman
because you made up the role that this
council is unique in having a special
representative of the People's Republic
of China and yet we don't mention the
word International
um anywhere in our promotion enhancement
protection of the cultural heritage and
assets of the country
um and I really think that this is
um
we are a worldwide stage uh and Council
Perry and I have been swapping emails uh
this week uh in the British Council in
China is looking to contact
Stratford
um to promote
Shakespeare will use Shakespeare to
promote the UK better in China
now let's grab Shakespeare as our own
and let us make sure that that becomes a
commitment for this Council to work
internationally rather than nationally
um I know Darren's got a itching to say
something but I have got a couple more
points
Mr Brooklyn did you want to come in yeah
can I just comment on the the objective
slash priority column because
these have been set for us by Council
previously we we have
um the the council plan Vision which was
set by Council back in 2019 and below
that then the specific objectives and
priorities to deliver against that
Vision so it's not always within the
gift of cabinet just to change
um what we're seeking to achieve in in
in in in the word and that where the
defined say for cp2b uh so sorry cb2a
that that has been signed up against
well we are looking for your
consideration of this afternoon are the
the opposed tasks to deliver against
that that overall objective if you are
seeking to change the The Wider
objective I think that would have to be
reported back to the council just to
accept that that's effectively a change
in policy position on what we're trying
to achieve there
thank you Mr
do you have any more points councilor
Kettle
um so well I mean I think thanks for
that clarification David I think
therefore under cp2a some of the
activities should look towards the
international stage rather than the uh
purely you know the items which are
listed there which are
um a little bit more locally focused I
mean after all we do have Shakespeare's
England uh which we do fund
um and have funded considerably in the
past and if that they are now working
with British Council that is an area we
need to follow given the request you
know the huge
um benefit we get from International
terrorism
um so that's that uh cp1c
um clearly as you quite know it's the
priority was set by Council David uh but
I'm just wondering that now Commonwealth
Games
um and the City of culture has sort of
come to an end there's a really much
more we can achieve on that but wait to
see
um
cp2b we focus on
so it's cp2c
CCTV CCTV crime disorder strategy
um I think several Community safety is
not just about cameras
uh this is clearly within my portfolio
and we are focusing very much on other
areas such as rural crime uh the safety
of women and girls
and to me the top priority even though
clearly rural crime is quite high in my
constituents uh county lines and I think
um you know we need to push
push these
push the book come in please
go on thank you right we have set a
cancel plan that sets these priorities
we have gone around the houses on more
than one occasion about the high level
objectives we talk about specifically
cultural and assets
um do we really need to spell out that's
both
intra International and national and
local and Regional these are high level
objectives it is not the role of this
cabinet to start defining and second
guessing and creating detailed
objectives and even down to policy
matters I think we have to set a broad
framework that we manage and we have
been through this on more than one
occasion and we've spent time and I for
one thought we had got to a landing on
this and I am disappointed
that we start to think about trying to
buy more than one member start to change
things on the who fear
um we have to give an overall steer to
this and I for one am comp tent with the
fact that we have high level objectives
signed off by Council and high level
actions and then we get the reporting on
the performance I I think we cannot
start to unpick and unravel what we've
already worked to and I would
urge members not to sacrifice the good
on the on the altar of the perfect and
to move forward with this councilor
shenton
then councilor Harvey thank you chairman
um I I
agree with what uh councilman Pemberton
said however point just a point of
clarification on cp2c
where we on page 107 where we say full
delivery of the CCTV project to include
earlswood CCTV camera
is that both cameras
there's more than one this says singular
not plural
it is it can be picked up afterwards I'm
quite happy I think
I'll pick take councilor pemberton's
point we are probably getting into
far too much detail
I think the interesting thing as well is
looking at Earl's wood
I am very well aware that things in
Earls would change and what was in the
original CCTV camera project May well
have now been enhanced
so you're looking physical chem solution
to me
sorry chair yeah as far as I'm aware it
so it has always it's been
two cameras for some time
one in one in Malt House Lane one in
um Valley road so it should be plural
and I'm quite happy to pick it up at a
later date but and I accept its detail
but it is
details so we picked them up later sorry
done too
I just respond as well yes I just wanted
them so I might point to the camera that
these are additional items which were
being asked to undertake as specific
new tasks if you like before the end of
the administration well before this the
council plan period in September like
next year canceled Kettle when when
you're quoting about the Royal crime
initiatives and I'm working on with the
community we're doing that as business
as usual in any case so these were the
additional tasks in effect above that of
the steady state within the organization
so there's a lot and and to be fair I
think it's a high Fair Point that we
might be able to include the delivery of
the actions out of the community Safety
Action Plan as we have done so with the
active Community Action Plan and the
social inclusion action plan
to recognize that we do annually set our
priorities in that particular area but
but otherwise they're supposed to
represent the additionality is something
which is new and why it's being reported
here rather than what we generally
undertake is an authority
it's a quick request really uh it's on
cp1b uh second point to reintroduce
regular senior politician and officer
briefing sessions could that include a
senior
possibly myself or not counselor Nigel
Rock
councilor Harvard did you want to come
in I simply wanted to support Council
prematin in relation to council kettle's
Point particularly about Shakespeare and
I would have thought if you look at cp1a
and the actions that are proposed under
there there is plenty of support there
for Shakespeare everything Shakespearean
councilman Parry thank you leader I just
wanted to highlight really that after
any major event in England whether it be
cultural or sporting it is the legacy of
that event that has the impact to the to
the districts and count as it was held
so we will all be benefiting from the
Commonwealth Games over the next five
years through greater participation in
in various Sports so I'm just wondering
if I could bring cabinet back to the
recommendations with your approval and
to recommend that we approve the
proposals very well done councilman
Parry can we approve the recommendation
on page 101
thank you so moving swiftly on to item
six uh stratford-upon-avon Gateway
development brief councilor Pendleton
thank you chair
members will be aware that it's been a
long-term aspiration of this Council
um for the gate the so-called Gateway
site to be developed and
um
members will also be aware of the
ongoing work to try and secure the site
and there's no further update to that
before uh before members ask for a
further any further questions
um but part and parcel of the process is
to ensure that
as we move forward there is a policy
framework and in conjunction with the
lead officer John careford
um the the notion is to create a
detailed master plan through a
supplementary planning document SPD
and that certainly was referenced as
being one of the milestones and way
forwards uh around the original sort of
work around a leveling up bid it's also
been a Cornerstone of the discussions
with the landowners and other potential
interested investment parties such as
the West Midlands combined Authority so
in order to kick that piece of work off
we do need to
um develop a development brief that does
need
the use of external Consultants to to
prepare that piece of work so you see
three recommendations before you on page
113 that the development brief which has
been the subjects have some detailed
discussion between officers and myself
as a portfolio holder is endorsed that
Consultants are commissioned and that a
budget sum of 50 000 pounds is funded
from General Reserve to uh to come from
that particular piece of work if there
are technical questions around the brief
I will defer of course to to John
careford
in particular
right
counts counselors unit it's just a query
because I had something in my memory
that there was an option over the
Windsor Street Car Park as far back as
2013 but I can't remember the detail but
you know
is is this relevant to this um this SPD
because so the Winter Street car park is
within the confines of the so-called
Gateway site uh and so uh to that extent
uh Windsor streetcar Park is relevant
it has been a long and winding road as
you might find going up and down a car
park
councilman Harvey yeah I've got four
questions should I pose four or deal
with them one at the time
okay can we uh is it relevant to ask
whether the development brief has been
agreed with the Shakespeare birthplace
trust and the Town Council is it
necessary has it been done
uh the short so thank you the short
answer is no this is the first time it's
come public
um but I don't think of this stage is
particularly relevant
um I think this is a quite a high level
brief that just crystallizes what's
already in the public domain and in
adopted plans the next stage which is
the detailed master plan that document
would require the full engagement with
stakeholders and The Wider community and
at a very high level those stakeholders
are on board with where we want to go so
we're it's not the right point in the
process yet thank you very quick
question question two is is 50k enough
or too much where did it come from are
we going to be coming back
um asking for more or um
Mr campus it is a bit of a finger in the
air but based on experience
um that uh I would say that is
um the right amount one would hope that
it could come in significantly less
um but I I think it's better to have a
figure you can for this flexibility in
order to get the the right outcome so
I'm confident we can do it certainly
within within that figure thank you and
it's in line with other pieces of
similar work I I just thought it was it
might be useful to have that aired in
public to make sure that that's
understood third question is the the
site includes four listed buildings and
are they to be retained or demolished
are they an impediment to the projection
of the scheme
Mr chairford well they certainly asked
her in impediment and obviously they're
they're part of our cultural heritage
and you know the planning position on
they they have great value and certainly
uh yeah we shouldn't harm them in in
that sense
um I'm confident the scheme could come
forward uh to incorporate them to reuse
them
um but again it's it's part of the
detailed Master planning
um approach that would follow that you'd
get a definitive answer to that but this
high level stage there's no reason why
they can't be retained and and brought
back into use to have a viable uh
bartender future too
final question can I find final question
is relates to use of terminology not
that I'm an expert in such matters
um
there's reference to
the use of the word council and I wonder
whether for instance let me give you an
example page 118 the third paragraph
third line
the develop this development resets a
vision for what the council wants to see
on this site is that true is it the
council or is it the cabinet
and so I I question oh
a question of the language who who
are all count if the council is being is
is if it's being said that the council
has approved then I would expect any
cancer any of the 36 councilors on the
council to say yes I've been partying to
this discussion or this decision and
it's a council decision if that if
that's the case that's fine if it's not
the case and it's mainly the cabinet
that is signing off this brief then
should not the reference be to should we
not check to ensure that we're using the
words Council and cabinet appropriately
I I think that Council has signed off on
the a broad future for the Gateway site
the Gateway site has been the subject of
much discussion
um by council members
um and therefore it follows to my mind
that a natural consequence of that is to
take the steps to give life to that
desire which includes the development
brief that's the ongoing the subsequent
SPD and therefore the use of the phrase
council is correct it is also untrue to
say that Gateway and the discussions
around Gateway are in the future for
example for a world Shakespeare Center
are merely products of the imagination
of the cabinet they are part of the
significant discussions and agreement
with the Shakespeare birthplace trust
with other charitable
organizations on site and have been part
and parcel of broader discussion so I
think I'm comfortable with the use of
the term Council
I think in this regard Capital are
speaking on behalf of Council in
relation to the the direction that's
already been set ultimately when the
master plan is set that will be a
council decision it won't be a cabinet
decision so this is the brief to do the
the detailed work to create the brief of
the the master plan that ultimately will
be accounts decision but I think I mean
you you are the cabinet acts on behalf
of Council in this regard
thank you Mr Brooklyn uh councilor
Jennings councilor Barker councilor
kettle
as far as I'm concerned we need this
high level brief to move forward I think
we need to move forward as soon as
possible I think it's an excellent
report and very happy to support it
Council Jennings councilor kettle
um absolutely underpin where cancer
Genesis is coming from I've just got one
bit of clarification that is on page 121
um fourth like in the bottom uh linking
the medieval new term with the Old Town
Center
um if it's medieval there's new town
there I'm just just purely descriptive
there it just seems like the um
slightly challenging in my mind to work
that one through where how old is the
old turn
you know
councilor Parry
um what I just wanted to ask and I'm I
may have have not seen it in the
paperwork oh are we going to be having a
beauty parade of Consultants or have we
got a a selected uh consultant in mind
uh thank you Mr chairman um no we'd have
to uh follow the council's tendering
processes and uh it gets tender and
assess those so yes it would be a parade
councilor shenton
thank you chair
um for me this is a no-brainer because
we uh it would be good to see a master
plan come out of this and for us to move
ahead so I think like like cancer
Jennings has said
it's hard to move on in that case
councilor shentenova tend to agree with
you so the recommendations uh the three
of them on page 113 uh can I have your
agreement to those recommendations
please members of cabinet
thank you so moving on to item seven
planning training hours which I'm sure
is a subject dear to councilor kettle's
heart councilor kettle
how long do you want me to address this
for Mr Joan
um
preferably councilor Kettle a great many
seconds
um I think um Mr grafton's Paper is is
very clear here
um I hope nobody has any concerns
without about increasing training from
30 minutes to 60 Minutes for those who
do attend
um planning meetings uh and I think I'll
probably try and get it over before the
first minute strikes
any questions comments members of
cabinet or shall we move counselor
Harvey
um appendix one
I don't recall having seen this piece of
paper before and on the basis that we're
going to approve this paper could I
request that it's circulated to all
councils
please that's a great so with that and
no further obvious comments from cabinet
recommendation on page 137
uh are we in agreement with that
recommendation members of cabinet
agreed thank you members of cabinet it's
uh moving swiftly on uh motion on notice
Freedom of Information log counselor
Kettle once again
thank you Mr chairman
um so there's an ocean motion is
requiring us to create a public log of
freedom information requests
um
I have to ask why
um the Warwick has just published one
but that was a very public matter which
related to the merger with Stratford
where there was a huge amount of press
interest but the whole the whole merger
process and after all these the two
councils did spend some two years and an
awful lot of time and as I've been told
quite a lot of money in that process so
I think in that case had we it had been
requested might have been something so
small to publish in fact we have
disclosed this
um an awful lot of the work we've done
we've discussed it in public but to put
every single freedom information request
in the public realm where every request
is by its very nature the wording of
which is unique they may follow a single
theme uh or a similar theme on each case
but each one comes from an individual
and they require answering in a
different way we therefore have to
include
every uh and I think we go we've got 970
requests from first of June 2020 to 31st
of May 2021
um sorry that was 1330 the following
year was 970.
that is a huge commitment on this
Authority and Mr grafton's team
to spend logging every return and what
the experience of other authorities has
been time after time is that how
everyone comes you publish it people
will still ask further questions
even though this information is already
published
um so we have a very
um you know we have a team who's dealing
with foreign information requests
everyone has dealt with appropriately
but do we need to publish it at a cost
at a very significant cost when this
Authority is going to face very
significant financial challenges I think
Mr Harvey and I are actually he's even
nodding to my comment
um a huge a huge resource requirements
to make this happen and what the
experience of other authorities has been
is that actually it has had no real
benefit to residents of those other
authorities
thank you chair
um
the principle of openness and
transparency is one to which every
single person around this table
subscribes and I would say that in
general terms as an authority we're the
good guys we tend to be
living those
tenants have been open and transparent
as far as we can and our officers are
very much signed up to that
and at a superficial level
this would seem to be in line with that
and would seem to follow on from that
however it's a dreadful idea
um
leaving aside
the uh
Financial cost element of actually doing
it leaving aside the time element
it's hugely inappropriate
um for a number of reasons
um
Freedom of Information requests firstly
tend to be from individuals around
specific issues and we're now and they
want to be able to make those inquiries
within a within a safe framework and now
we're talking about publishing that
information on a website
Freedom of Information requests are used
by commercial organizations on a regular
basis to find out information to enable
them to pitch for business I know this I
do this all the time
so we've then got to start doing work to
actually publish requests around
commercial requests which are just
pitches for business
and thirdly
sadly
Freedom of Information requests are
weaponized by individuals by
organizations by the media by our
political opponents and sometimes
supporters
and
that
then publishing bows then gives even
more air time to people who would seek
to
uh do a stand as an organization
and we also have to remember I had four
points that each in in a large number of
circumstances
Freedom of Information requests
um relate to an impact on individual
officers and their performance and their
decision making
and again I think it is inappropriate
that anything that starts to put that
into the public domain without context
is inappropriate and actually does
nobody any good I have seen no clamor by
anybody really that says I wish my my
decision for an foi request had been
public published you're not seeing the
information Commissioner's Office tell
us we should publish things in that way
if I've missed something I apologize but
frankly this is one of those it seems a
really neat idea but it's a dreadful
idea and I absolutely uh feel that it is
the wrong way to go and I would I would
be strongly urging cabinet to make the
recommendation that this this room this
notice of motion is rejected thank you
councilor shenton then councilor Cargill
mine's a very brief comment and I agree
totally with what council Pemberton says
it's detailed bureaucracy cost none of
this we need now and there is no legal
requirement to do this so why should we
do it
thank you councilor shenton councilor
Cargill thank you chat well as it
happened at the meeting this very
morning in this free chamber we were
discussing resources and the lack of
resources within the organization this
was just burden us even more
thank you councilor Cargill counselor
yes the um it was I've listened to the
debate and um take on board quite a few
of the points that that were made uh
it's certainly the point that I've had
residents say to me
um how do I find out about the
performance of the council and how well
it's performing and I have to say for
many people this current website of the
district council this District Council
compared to many other district councils
is very difficult to navigate and very
difficult to get clear information from
compared to some that you know across
the country that I've had a look at so
um
sorry it's just that if people have
taken the trouble if residents have take
the trouble
um to take up performance a a request
about the performance of the council
they usually have a reason to do so and
it was just it was just that
um if a resident has asked a question
about the performance then I think it
should be open we should be open about
it and um you know we don't have to
publish anything that would be you know
legally not possible within the state of
the law but I just felt they say I was
asked this question uh why is it that
Warwick District Council did this on
this one occasion and strapper didn't so
I thought I would ask that question
thank you councilor junid I have to say
uh having read this paper I mean total
agreement with councilor Pemberton and
councilor shenton I see
an awful lot of work an awful lot of
effort needed some considerable
downsides and frankly uh a few upsides
councilor kettle
I have just
confirmed with my colleague on the left
that if a member of the public gets a
response from the freedom information
team follow me a request there is no
reason why they shouldn't publish up
themselves through
WhatsApp groups through the press or any
other reason as they feel it's so
important to do so but to cover all 900
Plus for the sake of possibly one or two
who believe that their response should
be published if it is that fundamentally
crucial and it relates to Stratford then
the limited Courier uh old Stratford
Herald should be if it's that important
would unsure be delighted to cover that
comment
thank you councilor Kettle so the
recommendation then on page 100 sorry
now uh the camp yes
sorry just an in defense of the
criticism of the council's uh website
and I.T people and people who work on
that I find it very easy to navigate and
uh and very easy to get around
councilor Crump
thank you Peter um just a couple of
points firstly covers my previous
chairmanship role when I was chair of
audit and standards and that used to
come on a regular basis the Freedom of
Information requester Mr grafton's not
in saying I'm not talking rubbish maybe
she's good
um and it was a lot of time spent by
offices for no really added value or
very little added value and I agree with
cancer Pemberton lots of commercial
organizations we're using it to try and
get information particularly around land
charges was one of the cases that it
used to be so
um on for openness and honesty and value
and transparency and that's the whole
point of scrutiny and the overview
integration here which I now currently
chair would I say this was value for
money and better use of our resources I
would say no personally he's the next
officer of a district council which had
to answer these uh Freedom of
Information requests I found them quite
demotivating
from a personal point of view and if we
want to make best use of our staff if we
want to encourage and retain our staff I
think we need to use their skills
properly not on something like this
thank you councilor Trump a very good
intervention so on page
143.22
then I believe what we are saying is we
recommend to council responses to foi
and dir requests are not published in
line with current practice can I have
your agreement to that please members of
cabinet
thank you members of cabinet so moving
on to item nine this is reach out and
help a funding request for Citizens
advice south or actually councilor
Barker
got my pages stuck together sorry
um
I was still reading Chris's but
um
we are asking here for
um a small award to bridge a gap with
citizens advice South Yorkshire
um for a further two months
um casw or applying for lottery
sorry is this
camera we just
discussing actually whether leaders
already made a decision in relation to
6107 I thought the leader had already
made a decision on the leader's decision
yes on that particular
David
he's made a decision hasn't he or I have
the list of plants the leader's decision
was regarding the other report that came
to informal cabinet on the same morning
excellent so we'll carry on um it's for
six thousand one hundred and seven
pounds which isn't an awful lot of money
um to while they're waiting to see what
happens with their Lottery bid and then
we will have to reconsider um I would
just make the point that at the moment
doing anything that wouldn't be
supportive of Citizen advice would be
shooting ourselves in both feet the
bottom and the head simultaneously so my
recommend the recommendations are here
on page 147 and I just think we should
get on with it
councilman Kettle count are taking an
instructional Barker my colleague I I
would propose this and I think it is our
immediate support we're going through
very difficult times uh and for cost of
six grand
um given what we might have been
spending on a New Freedom of Information
officer which we haven't uh I think this
is this is seriously important to the
residents of Stratford and I don't think
we even need to debate it looking for
the nods around the table yeah right
sorry uh councilman Trump you wish to
make a point Thank you just just very
briefly I I accept this is an interim
report from the project and the final
report will be submitted in October I
noticed there were 14 areas they were
being knocked at and it'd be interesting
or whether the local member in those
Wards would be able to receive
information regarding the number of
interventions and the type of
interventions uh forgot obviously
confidentiality is uh respected
um to see if there is a problem that
needs to be tackled even more so I think
it's got the information a lot of the
information is there but it would be
good to see if there's a particular
problem in this in a certain Ward
Mr Platts
I think there'll definitely be some data
sharing issues around that Council to be
honest with you because say it's the
citizens advice who will gain that data
um we can ask them if we they would be
happy to share that data with us but
there is no
um legally binding situation where we
say to them we want to know who those
people are
thank you
Mr Platts
um I do think that councilor Crump has
raised a good point because it would
give us an indication of what the issues
actually are and perhaps Mr Platz is
another way of identifying that
Mr Graf just as a general point to help
members um if you published statistical
information in other words it's just
numbers not identifying individuals and
that usually enables us to get around
data protection issues unless the cohort
is so small that it's obvious who the
individuals are so I think it's probably
best to say we take that one away and
see what we can do
within the within the legal parameters
thank you Mr Grafton
um whilst the uh paper on page 153 does
list those 14 uh lsos which Council
Crump has referred to
um I would like this assurance that if
somebody needing support is outside
those lsos they will still be
um
eligible
or capable of getting support from
uh I noticed Mr Platz nodding so I'm
assuming
that's right
okay so recommendations on page 147 are
we all in agreement with that members of
cabinet great thank you members of
cabinet
uh I've raised them already thank you
we haven't had any um meetings for a
while so we've crossed over so
um it'll be the next cabinet meeting
there there might be one or two shall we
say
thank you councilor
uh so now the unblock items uh cabinet
work program climate change panel and
member development working group nobody
has uh asked for the items to be
discussed so they are all accepted as on
block items
no urgent business
so therefore I declare the meeting
closed